History has a lot of traditions that predict the end of the world - all of them were suicidal - but so far
There are some people who believe that 2012 is the end of the world
Why 2012? Because of an ancient Mayan calendar (obviously)
The Mayan calendar is not only recorded for days and years, but also for ages
5 Fiat. If they can easily make a calendar go
1000 years in the future. But of course 1000 years in the future
From 1000 years ago bring us to the present when the Mayan calendar stops the year 2012
People who think they are cultured through spiritual practices have decided that the wise Mayan people have stopped making calendar because they are
Know that the world will end, because they are happy though
Who are they Amion - but people have a view that 2012 was a great spiritual awakening
Or re-operating the world - widening the irrationality of the Maya dwelling who spent time pulling out
Throne chains through the year People probably did not have the idea
For the average person the idea: that the end of the calendar means the end of the world
Is a strange conclusion to think about. After all, the amount of time in the universe
The stones are finite and limited, so at some point the Maya people must stop sculpting
Calendars. But do not care
What has to remain on the fringes of endorsement is turning into hysteria with
The 2012 film, which swept the Academy Awards and many nominations for the Amy Awards for End of the World films
:::::::deep breath:::::::
History Channel
After all, NASA became so immersed in this situation that they had to take time
From their time of building robots and pushing and expanding knowledge
And their civilized schedule to write a Web page explaining that no stone-age society can sacrifice human beings
Without wheels to tow carts or glass for the manufacture of a telescope and do not know more about
Science at the beginning of history more than scientists today
But the review of the madness of the world on everything is a stormy and unpredictable prediction of the earth
Including the reflection of the magnetic poles (a process that unfolds over a geological time, not one day)
Geological time range, not one day) A set of Planet X puzzles
No space scientist finds him a local star exploding (though
Of the absence of any candidate). Space invasion (laughable
It) and a time beam, no matter what
Gomez. A reasonable man at this stage will wonder
How the Mayan population that they could predict physical anomalies thousands of years ago
And millions of miles away could not see the Spaniards coming from the Pacific Ocean (Atlantic)
This is because the Mayans did not predict the end of the world. Only people who claimed to be Mayan residents
They knew about the Apocalypse they clearly are not Mayans